I'm Nick Evans I'm a data scientist at
Shopify I'm here to tell you about
real-time risk management using Kafka
Python and spark streaming a little bit
about myself
Shopify is based in Ottawa and I'm from
Northern Ontario which is Canada I like
the cold I like hockey - in case you
couldn't tell by the backgrounds that
showed up when I first plugged into my
computer and the Hat - I was actually
gonna wear my Jersey but I decided
against it because he might not take me
seriously it's in my case over there
though so yeah so Shopify is a commerce
platform so if you make a hat like this
this nice hat here and you want to sell
it online you go to shop for column sign
up for a store take a picture of the Hat
and then within probably like I'd say 2
minutes you can start accepting credit
card transactions we do a lot of other
stuff like shipping Billa code
integrations with Facebook other things
like that and if you become really
successful and you have enough money to
buy a brick-and-mortar store you can
actually install our app on your iPad
get a cash register and a credit card
swiper and just accept credit card
transactions from your physical store so
on that note honor rating credit card
transactions is actually pretty risky
there's a potential for loss if a stolen
credit card is used to make a purchase
as the bank recovers the money from us
that's called a charge back if a
merchant does have some money in their
bank account then we end up having to
foot the bill
it's also possible possible they might
sign up and then accept fraudulent
transactions and then leave and then how
do we get the money back we can't so
someone might create they also might
create a fake product that they never
intend to ship and then sell that to
unsuspecting customers and then we end
up footing the bill there because they
usually disappear before the chargebacks
come in they might say like oh this
product will ship in December 2016 and
then be gone by like January that's what
we're sorry January 2016 where's my
mouse there it is so we need to be quick
at this underwriting we pay our
merchants the money that they capture
through credit cards I think about 2 or
3 days after they capture the
transaction and we need to check these
credit card transactions and stop the
bad actors from stealing money from us
the problem is that the vast majority
these transactions are actually
legitimate because there's a lot of good
people in the world and we also have a
ton of transactions and we really don't
want to punish the good merchants by
holding back their money longer than we
need to they earned that money and they
need that cash flow to keep running
their business otherwise they'd shut
down and then we'd shut down we also
need to avoid losing money so we could
lose hundreds of thousands of dollars a
month if we were to just ignore the
problem which that's a that's a lot of
money we need to ensure that our risk
analysts are spending their precious
time looking at the right shops and
right credit card transactions so here's
some numbers about Shopify ten billion
dollars that's us cumulative processed
we've facilitated that much since we
started 2006 I think yeah and 175,000
plus merchants including some big names
like Tesla Motors Wikipedia and github
if you bought a github t-shirt that's
through July 14 k events a second that's
the number of events that are coming
from Shopify and that's about 1.2
billion a day so it's a lot of data I
mean not as much as a like like the
medical data but it's still like a ton
of data to process and then we have like
five risk analysts looking through it
right now looking through all of our
transactions I believe other companies
have taken let's just throw a lot of
people at the problem and hired teams of
like hundreds of risk analysts we try to
we kind of want to do with a smart way
first and then higher up if we need to
so I said I like talkie and I'm gonna
deliver our risk analysts are kind of
like goalies right that's my friend Alex
he's a very good goalie but we were not
a very good hockey team so he stops a
lot of pucks and they're good at like
he's very good at saving pucks but if
you know a bunch of people are shooting
pucks at you you're not gonna be able to
stop many there's a lot of padding and
not a lot of net space so we need
something we need to build something
that stops this hope factor of relying
on the goalie we need a system that can
filter the high volume event streams
that Shopify application produces so
that our risk analysts aren't overloaded
we also need to make sure we're not
sending them the non risky events as
much as possible and we need to make
sure that we are sending them any
actual risky events so this is false
positive true positive all that kind of
stuff they want to reduce their workload
while ensuring there are no risky events
that don't go in their deck go unnoticed
don't go unnoticed so we built this
thing that kind of that's my friend Evan
he's a defender so he's supposed to stop
the pucks from getting to my friend Alex
and you can see he's patting my friend
Alex on the back so Alex must have made
a good save which means Evan shouldn't
be smiling because he didn't do his job
so spark streaming allows us to do
real-time data processing we need to
decide we can decide which events to
take a closer look we built a stream
processor that filters down these event
streams these super high-volume event
streams into not so high-volume event
streams and then we do an HTTP POST for
each risky event out to a custom-built
case management software these risk
analysts then open up that software look
through the queues and decide weather
events are risky as an aside we call it
pat-down it's themed after what happens
in an airport security line if you get
flagged for closer review so necessary
introduction to Kafka zookeeper and
spark streaming so who's heard of Kafka
hands so most of you I'd assume
zookeeper less less so but that's what
CAF queues is for coordination spark
streaming or spark in general yeah okay
fair and fair fair amount so Kafka is a
fault tolerant and distributed
publish/subscribe message buffer
originally written at linkedin you
define a list of topics and produce
messages these topics so these topics
are like like order placed or product
created or something like that and then
you consume those messages elsewhere
later our main use for this is be able
to log events super quickly from the
Shopify applications that we don't have
to do a slow database call or like
polling the database from our external
application it's super fast to write
these events like it's very low cost
then we need be able to read these
events from another application say an
automated mailer or a dashboard or
dashboard for the sales team or
something like that so it has a
ridiculously high throughput due to some
engineering decisions ridiculously as a
technical word I think so it has a
retention policy which means that it
will only Garon
teas the events will be stored for X
hours or days most of our topics are 7
days it has an at least once guarantee
meaning you'll hear the messages at
least once but you could hear it twice
or three times or a hundred times or
something like that so you need some
kind of deduplication if you care about
that these topics are also broken up
into partitions which you can see up
here so partitions are basically
partitions of the data and we want to
ensure all of our data for a specific
shop is on the same partition because
ordering is only guaranteed within that
partition so if you care about these
events in order from that shop you need
to make sure they're all in the same
partition and if it slows down you add
some more computers so it's a money
problem and not a computer problem this
is a side note we like I said that
there's a retention policy of seven days
we actually have this thing that comes
along reads Kafka and writes it down to
HDFS so we have an infinite retention
policy if you think of it like that
so zookeeper zookeeper is used by spark
streaming and by Kafka for coordination
it's a distributed data store that
stores data in kind of a tree format
like you can see here yeah we store
configuration deals for spa
details for spark streaming actually
here I'll go back for a second you can
see these like indexes here like 0 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 those are called offsets and
it's basically just like an event ID for
that partition when you're consuming
from a caf-co topic you store the event
that you've received in zookeeper and
it's a really well-written piece of
software that's admittedly hard to use
but once you've got it used working it's
it's working really well if the
streaming job ends up shutting down we
ask Kazuki / hey where'd we leave off
and it works really well for that
so here's sparks streaming I'll kind of
since most you put your hands up for
Sparkle just skip over the like the
intro to spark stuff because it's easy
to cover here - it's the stream
processing framework built on top of
spark
it's spark is really good at
distributing data processing it has a
little bit of overhead but it's it's
really it makes it really easy for
programmers to ignore the fact that your
job is being run in a cluster its main
level of abstraction is the RDD which i
believe stands for a Brazil
to distribute a dataset and it's just
the data set you can do map filter
reduce all of those standard operations
on so it splits up the data across the
cluster for you so you can get the fast
parallel processing and it's written in
scala but it has a really good Python
API and I chopped fired the data team
uses Python that's our main language I
think probably most of you too since
you're here
similar to Kafka it has an at least once
guarantee spark streaming does assuming
you set it up properly you can get it
exactly once but that's hard and we
didn't bother with that we figured we'd
solved the problem in another way so
it's all in memory unless you tell it to
save it down to HDFS that's useful for
reasons we'll get to spark streaming
breaks up the incoming data into chunks
and then puts it into an RDD that you
can do operations on this is called a
district discretized stream stream or d
stream that's the core abstraction and
what it is is you basically micro batch
the streaming data so every 30 seconds
say or every half second you take a data
to take all of your incoming data put it
into an RDD process the RDD and then
keep on doing that infinitely or until
your job dies the breaking up of the
data the timing can be customized
I think it's minimum 500 milliseconds
maximum I don't know if there's a
maximum but you should probably maximum
because it stores it all in the memory
if you're serving web requests with
spark streaming you probably want to set
it to the lowest possible because then
you'll have the highest or lowest
latency these jobs need to be very
heavily optimized though because you
won't be processing the data as fast as
it comes in if they're not optimized
which is a big problem and we'll get to
that we don't really care too much about
this timeliness as long as it's within a
couple hours like if the risk analysts
have seen it within a couple hours who
cares like what's a two day three day
payout so we set it to conservative 30
seconds which allows for much higher
throughput but higher latency each back
spark streaming ask for a block of
offsets from Kafka creates an RDD from
the returned event and as I said earlier
if your processing time is larger than
your batches
sighs you'll fall behind and you might
not be able to keep up so the way spark
used will still work sorry the way spark
streaming works in most cases is using
these things called receivers receivers
what they do basically is it loads
chunks of data stores it into a queue in
memory and then your spark engine comes
along after and processes the queued
data
so again if you're keeping up with your
stream you'd have one thing of queued
data and then you'd pick that up a
second it's queued so it's like super
quick it works pretty well I'll give a
demo of it up here it's a slight
simplification but it should give you a
general idea of how it works so you have
between t0 and t1 so these are your
these are your batches t0 to t1 is one
batch t0 t1 to t2 is another batch see
if these events coming in from t0 to t1
the receiver builds an RDD out of those
events then the spark engine just picks
it up and runs your just your defined
functions on it while that's happening
you also have more events coming in
build another ID RTD process that and
then more events so each time window a
bit I already said that receivers are
designed to work with all data sources
not just the buffer did ones like Kafka
like I said Kafka you can ask it for a
specific event and you can keep on
processing that event there are other
spark streaming data sources like you
can basically watch in HD HDFS directory
and any new files you come in you
process it but like you can't yeah
yeah yeah yeah in front of the processor
yeah it receives it stores it in the
memory and then you know when your
processor is ready it'll pick up one of
those batches in in order that's the
important part - yeah it's part of the D
stream so there are a couple of problems
with receivers at least for us it's a
it's pretty good great first start but
it wasn't really designed with Kafka in
mind it was designed with the general
case in mind so the first problem is
checkpointing the only way to get at
least once delivery makes it hard to
deploy new code so what that means is it
takes the date like checkpointing takes
the data that you've received
well checkpointing plus right ahead logs
takes the data that you've received but
have not yet processed and it saves it
to HDFS so if your job fails you just
look at HDFS and say oh hey look there's
some data there we'll start off from
there the big problem with this is that
it actually saves your set of
instructions your directed acyclic graph
everyone's familiar with it what that is
yeah so it loads that - meaning you can
never deploy new code like you can you
just unless you come up with like some
tricky way of around it you're like
you're just stuck we're using that code
forever
yeah which that's not like in our in our
case we do update our code so could the
code reload itself I don't know I don't
yeah I guess that could work but you'd
have to hack the spark internals I think
yeah so it's a little bit I think would
be a hacky solution but the other thing
is zookeepers updated with which offsets
you've received when you receive the
data not when you're done processing
with it so if you don't have check
pointing on here's what I was saying
about the at least once guarantee if you
don't have check pointing on you will
receive the data tells ooh keeper we're
done like I don't need to hear this
event again and then your dog job dies
in the very first event so you basically
post test process none of the events
sorry
you basically process none of the events
which is problematic because then when
you ask zookeeper hey watch what have I
heard it tells you something that you've
heard but not processed and it also
makes traditional Kafka monitoring tools
less useful because if your processors
falling behind
Kafka monitoring traditionally asks hey
Kafka what's the latest offset hey
zookeeper what's the latest offset this
consumers received and it kind of shows
you like you know a graph of like help
your let your leg basically so you want
to keep it like very low and this you
can't really tell if you're if your
processors falling behind which is
actually a problem the last problem is
it's kind of duplicating work because
caf-co already has this buffer so why
have two buffers again receivers were
designed for the general case which is
not cow calf gives a very specific
engineering has some very specific
engineering choices which makes it
better to do it with something different
which receiver 'less this was added I
think maybe January or later and it was
presented at the SPARC summit and it's
pretty awesome it's specifically
designed for Kafka although I think
other data sources similar to caf-co
might start using it you handle all the
offset management yourself which is
unfortunate you have to actually like
pull the office like figure out what
offsets are know how to talk to sue
keeper and do all that stuff but you get
a lot of power worth it so the best part
about this in my opinion is you can tell
zookeeper after you've actually
processed the data after you're done
with that that batch so if there's a
problem before that while you just
replay data and that's where the at
least once guarantee comes in you might
process half of your batch and then it
dies and then the rest of your batch is
unprocessed but then you just start up
from there again you reprocess all those
events and then process the unfinished
events and then update zookeeper again
the downside is there's a lot more work
when it comes to zookeeper management
you actually have to write code to
figure out how to talk to zookeeper how
to talk to Kafka and do all the stuff
yourself the receiver this approach
actually does all this for you which is
kind of nice but again there's there's
problems with that so hopefully it'll
mature as spark streaming gets older
which I think that's the plan and they
might provide us a nice simple API to
say RDD commit or something like that
like say I've I'm done with this one a
downside of this another
another downside of the receiver this
approach is the API for Python is not
quite at parity with the API for Scala
it's getting there slowly but like the
way they work is they implement the
Scala code and then someone else comes
along and says hey or they could use the
Python API so that it then the
documentation is also not up-to-date so
it'll say you can't do a lot of the
things that you actually can do in
Python so it kind of discourages you
you're like dammit I can't do that but
then you look at the code and it's like
no it's it's there you can you can do it
so I've been updating some of the
documentation there as I have
encountered it and then the main
downside is is super experimental and
we're okay with that
so so how it works
here's another diagram is you get some
events then the next time you process
those events and then you update
zookeeper and then you get some more
events at that time and then you process
it so it's a little bit simpler as you
can see there's no receiver in the
middle so the general structure of how
we built our streaming jobs we don't use
checkpointing again and it's not
necessary to get that at least once
guarantee you load the cough cough sets
from zookeeper if they exist so like you
know you ask hey what if I process up to
if not you start from earliest or latest
available offset whatever is your choice
then you tell spur X for me to create a
d-- stream that consumes from kefka
starting at the specified offsets you
define your processing strap step like
filter out your non risky events you
define your output step like post the
data to a case management software and
then you actually save those offsets of
the most recently processed event to
catheter to zookeeper and then you
actually start your streaming
application like I was saying you define
your dag and then you start it after
you've defined it you can't add new
steps after you've already started your
streaming context so here's here's the
example that I'll give you guys we
filter risky products so hair extensions
are apparently an industry standard for
like super risky products you guys know
what that is like like the you attach it
to your hair to make it longer
apparently that's just like almost
always fraud and then a couple of the
other things I don't know what a Wi-Fi
pineapple is but I think it's like a
like a gem box or something like that
similar to that travel package that's
just because you're not allowed to sell
air travel over stripe which is what
powers our payments provider and then
vaporizer all the other things iPhones
pharmacy and then cannabis which is
legal to sell but we still want to look
into it in case they're trying to sell
it over Shopify payments which is not
allowed yeah Gucci - I don't understand
that one
so here's roughly how it works and this
is just for one batch like we're just
gonna look at this it's just like one
batch of 30 seconds for us so we get all
of these products well these are product
titles for example so here extensions
nice shoes sweet bag cannabis Taylor
Swift she t-shirt I'd buy that and then
Gucci and then you run the filtering
step on it to filter out things that
aren't risky or rather things that are
filter in things that are risky you do
some mapping on it that just like
converts it to a JSON object which you
can then post to our case management
software and this is a bit of a
simplification there is a lot of code
involved behind this but here's the bulk
of our streaming job like we just do a
map filter some filters we format the
record we format these things called
triggers and then we like we do a check
of our output contract which just makes
sure that all the types are what we
expect them to be and all the fields are
there so here's one thing that is quite
important in streaming jobs so some
streaming jobs say the risky products
one all you need to know about that
event is contained inside of that event
like that event has everything you need
to know what to decide whether it's
risky or not but sometimes you might
want to ask like okay tell me the shops
that have had orders in the last hour of
over $10,000 and we might want to look
into those especially if they're like
newer shops because maybe they're just
like testing a bunch of stolen credit
cards right so the built in time
windowed functions aren't quite ready
for prime time yet they window based on
the received time of the event not the
time the event was created so you you
know you send out your event from
Shopify and then you receive it three
days later by the streaming application
that will be included in like the window
kind of weirdly it also requires check
pointing to be enabled which as
discussed earlier has its own
limitations
you need check pointing because you're
not gonna be able all of this data in
memory you need to save it somewhere so
they use check pointing like that there
actually is kind of a workaround for
this but I won't get into that
we haven't done it yet but we're
planning on implementing our own time
windowed functions that get some of this
get around some of these shortcomings
but TD or T tasks I think is this github
handle he's the core developer of spark
streaming he's actually said that hey if
we build some functions and everyone
just builds their own anyways like those
functions aren't good enough so they're
gonna be they're gonna be working on
this I think in 1.6 or 1.7 which is very
welcome so the future time windowed
functions that's kind of a necessity for
the non-trivial jobs again in the case
of if you want to know aggregates for
the last hour or three hours or
something like that performance tweaks
so our jobs of just like we wrote them
and they've just managed to keep up they
haven't been super taxing we haven't
spent any time on this there's a
penchant for a lot of games games but we
haven't really needed to we haven't done
anything super complex other than say
checking that event against a an
in-memory list of things called a
broadcast in spark and then we've done a
couple joins you can actually join D
streams to rdd's which might like it be
a historical data set that you're
interested in you can join D streams to
D streams to I need a lot of cool stuff
so machine learning here's the one that
probably most of you will be interested
in I think this is like a fairly data
science II conference so we have these
risk analyst decisions in this case
management software we can actually
build a model about these decisions like
using that is like the I guess the
ground truth they're like the 1 or 0 the
the true or false
and then we could probably build some
smart models not even necessarily
related relating just specifically to
like product events but maybe shop
events or something
shop related events so improve
monitoring
we're only monitoring the basics right
now like processing
and then number of events processed per
per minute but you might want to monitor
something like how much time it takes to
process each event on average different
things like that
the next thing another buzzword Apache
Cassandra it's actually pretty cool you
can use it as a very fast key value
looka store for for your jobs so say if
you want to every hour you want to build
a dataset for the last 10 days which is
outside of our retention policy and you
want to check each event against that
built dataset you can store that into
Cassandra and then when you want to look
up the value for that shop you can you
can do it without actually having to use
the time-weighted functions because
again the retention policies only 7 days
so you can't do ten days of aggregates
and then an approved receiver less API
like I was saying you have to do all of
this offset management yourself so I
kind of want to work on something like
that where you can just do our DDOT
commit when you're done with it like
when you're done processing and it will
just handle all of that stuff for you so
slide 4 icon credits I used some icons
from this awesome project called the
noun project they have free icons some
of them you don't need to give credit
for some of them you do we're hiring
Shopify comm slash career so if this
interests you come talk to me or go to
that website and then thank you if you
have any if you have any questions you
can tweet at me or I guess find me on
the website at the conference website
this was a this is a longer topic last
time because there's a more chatty of a
group but I assume you're all holding
your questions until now so questions
yeah
yeah it's just repeated so if the
question was is Kafka distributed like
is the buffer distributed yeah if the
the level of level of parallelism comes
from those partitions so if you have
like a replication factor of 1 which
means like if you lose one node you'll
lose your data for that node you have a
replication factor of 1 and you have 10
partitions you'd have 10 nodes you might
set the replication for factor over to 2
I think ours is 3 so we could lose up to
3 to 2 nodes and not have data data loss
and that's scopes of partition and each
each partition has a leader like who's
the most up-to-date person and then it
handles all of the the synchronization
in behind-the-scenes so yeah if
something slows down you add more
computers
yep
yeah so the question was if you have two
streams you could join them together
into one stream and do operations on
that and the answer is yeah you can
union streams you can do joins on
streams you can do like bits on the
spark spark streaming API yep
yeah
so the question was have we looked into
ways of getting around the like getting
an exactly once guarantee because it's
dangerous when you're building models
you might duplicate events like machine
learning models so we haven't really had
that much in the way of duplication
duplicated events it's only when our
streaming jobs die that we ever get
these duplicated events there are a
couple ways actually meant to talk about
that but I guess I forgot to add the
slide about just the ways that you can
get exactly once there's two main ways
there might be more but this one is that
every talk everyone talk about
idempotence which means that if you send
the same event to your thing twice it'll
just know that it's already heard that
and it won't do anything with it and
that's what we use our rails app like
our case management software is a rails
app it is just a database constraint we
craft an identifier based on a couple
things and then send that off the rails
app if it hears it again it's just like
cool already heard that great the other
way is to use I'm less familiar with
this way but you can if you have a data
source that you're streaming to and that
data source is transactional you can
actually update zookeeper after every
single event using the offset yeah it's
not the easiest or so every event or the
other way would be to be transact the
entire batch so if you have like a half
second batch you start the transaction
insert or multi insert or whatever the
command is and then commit and if it
fails in time before then your database
will rollback so that's like the better
way of doing it for a couple reasons but
idempotence is just easier and I like
the easy way so but there are a couple
other things there's a couple of
theories on that I think most people
with the machine learning models they
generally try and build them you know
once a day or like once every week or
something like that and then just use
the built predictor if their data
doesn't change too much if your data is
changing really fast ly then that's a
bit of a problem you wanna be able
update in real time it's a hard problem
yeah I think the joke that the other guy
who gave a similar talk to me said if
someone tells you they're going to give
you exactly once they're they're trying
to sell you something
are there questions yeah so the question
was one of the advantages to spark
streaming compared to some other
technologies and I actually forgot to
add a slide on that too I did give this
talk a couple weeks ago and I had these
written down I guess I just forgot to do
it so we tried a bunch of them not
celery
we tried storm we tried I think Sam's is
another one I did not like I was not the
one doing that I was just handed spark
streaming and then I built it but I do
know the reason why we chose spark
streaming and it just comes down to
developer simplicity we already use
spark so the onboarding time for the
training like I knew a new data
scientist to build a streaming job is
like hey here's the slight differences
between our existing stack to the spark
streaming stack here's some things you
need to think about when you're
developing a streaming job versus a
batch job go and and she over there he
he built one he onboard it pretty
quickly and had a PR out within like a
day or two right it's pretty quick so
there are criticisms and of spark
streaming it's it's fairly immature and
they're kind of in shipping mode they're
trying to get as much features out as
possible so it kind of leads to some
bugs that come out but it actually
worries been working pretty well for us
and has been some of our most reliable
spark jobs running actually the
engineers have told me I think the
industry standard is storm and we are
pretty seriously considering storm I
think partially gave a talk to talks on
storm yesterday or at least one was
about storm the other one was it touched
on storm and yeah we were seriously
considering that but the thing that we
went with spark streaming was because we
already ran spark
sorry um a lot the ones that we're
actually processing right now the ones
we have stream processing jobs we have a
vote I think six or seven in production
none of them are too high volume I think
the highest volume is like 1,000 events
a second which is like really like
nothing at all we have like I said about
14,000 events a second in total I think
that's probably since I give this talk
last time I've updated the number I
think it's probably about like 1817 that
number goes up super quickly it's kind
of scary but yeah do you add more
computers if it slows down sorry it's
pretty quick well ours is 32nd batching
so an events produced and then spark
streaming cares about it it might take
up to 30 seconds 30 seconds plus some
amount to receive it but you can set it
for like 500 milliseconds sure yeah are
for which thing sure
okay so the answer this question is kind
of complicated we use and the question
was how many nodes are we using to
process these events so we use yarn for
resource allocation IV everyone's heard
of yarn or like at least has been
introduced to it so yeah we have these
configuration options that say give this
job this many cores this X this Y and we
kind of just went with like pretty
liberal defaults and we probably use a
little bit more a lot more resources and
we actually need our cluster itself is
about 60 nodes that's for SPARC and for
SPARC streaming but like the actual
resource these jobs use is miniscule
like we could you can you can easily run
all of our production jobs on your
laptop
yeah like and in fast it in fact that be
faster cuz there's no like parallelism
going on so yeah when you get sorry
like in the same cluster
the question was why do we put our spark
streaming jobs with our spark jobs it
was just easy we are did the
infrastructure it was set up and it's
been working so far I think we're
actually going to be separating that out
in the future but for now it's it's been
working so
yeah this one's a bit of a the question
was what formats the data and Kafka this
one's a little bit of an embarrassment
it's JSON so like where our lead data
engineering lead jokes that were burning
down forests in the Amazon when we
really should probably switch over to a
better or not better JSON is awesome but
like a more efficient format we do have
raw like nginx logs in Kafka too but any
kind of event that we're processing with
this risk stuff is probably going to be
a structured JSON event
oh yeah yeah so the question was are
these structures like schema I guess so
we kind of messed up when we first
started with Kafka we had another
logging system that we had built before
that kind of had like topics which is
the Kafka concept and then event names
which the schema was on the event name
not on the topic we have like a you know
check out flow for where you go to put
your credit card and admin flow where
you actually go to administer your store
and that's what our events were scoped
to was this topic which time do I have
two more okay so yeah the the the schema
was on the event name and we're trying
to migrate actually towards a topic
level schema which were we're in the
process of all new events are basically
going to be topic level schema but right
now they're schema to this event name
field and back on your other question or
the question that I thought you asked
we're actually trying to move to Avro
and some other like some pairing of the
two I'm not too familiar with like those
but that I think offers the schema and
also offers a more efficient message
format it's just like this was just like
the we try to go the easiest approach
first and then change it after it's just
the quickest way to ship features right
so
the consistency of order on a mono
partition across partitions not easily
yeah the question was can you keep order
across partitions the answer is not
easily and the reason is complicated if
you have any more questions you can come
talk to me too or tweet at me the things
up there I just changed my Twitter
handle because my old one was like
impossible so I hope that's correct but
yeah it's correct I tried it yeah so
thank you